The visual tail you see trailing from a comet
has nothing to do with its direction of travel.
It's actually because solar winds push on
its surrounding gasses, so that it always
points away from the Sun.
A traffic jam once lasted for more than 10
days, with cars only moving 0.6 miles a day.
If you could convert the mass in a one-kilogram
bag of sugar into energy, it would be enough
to drive a car non-stop for 100,000 years.
People who feel lonely tend to wake up more
frequently throughout the night whilst sleeping.
Monty Python's film Life of Brian was marketed
in Sweden as 'The film that's so funny, it
was banned in Norway.'
Woolly Mammoths were still around when the
Egyptian Pyramids were being built.
An Olympic rower named Henry Pearce once won
a race even though he stopped along the way
to let some ducks pass by.
Everyone has a unique smell except for identical
twins.
Asking someone "where are you" is a recent
phenomena.
Before we had mobile phone, the only way we
could talk to people is if we already knew
where they were.
If you touch your tongue whilst yawning it
can stop the yawn.
If you start with 1 penny and doubled your
money every day, it would only take 27 days
to become a millionaire.
In the entire state of Ohio in 1895, there
were only two cars on the road, and they crashed
into each other.
Dr. Suess wrote "Green Eggs and Ham" to win
a bet against his publisher who thought that
he could not complete a book using only 50
words.
If you were to remove all of the empty space
from the atoms that make up every human on
Earth, the entire world's population could
fit inside an apple.
In 1367, King Charles V of France explicitly
banned the wearing of shoes shaped like penises.
Sloths sometimes mistakenly grab their own
arm instead of a tree branch with can lead
to a fatal fall.